[Music]
Kennedy and joining us now with more
reaction to the media's coverage of the
Vegas shooting is the TMZ founder and
host Harvey Levin and also you can catch
Harvey right here on the Fox News
Channel his brand new hit series called
objectified it airs this Sunday night
8:00 p.m. Eastern and this week his
guest good friend of this program
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu Harvey good to see you thank
you for joining us I know one of the
things that I always love is that you
hit you reach younger audiences and a
lot of your show is about fun and
entertainment and Hollywood but you do
segments that really reach and touch
your audience what was the reaction from
a younger audience considering a lot of
this crowd that were victims of the
shooting were young people what was the
reaction this week despair it is
absolute despair
you know this we've seen so many of
these killings but you know it reminds
me in some ways Sean
of the way the Vietnam War resonated in
ways that other wars hadn't because you
saw it on TV you saw the gunfire on TV
and you know we have seen bits and
pieces of these mass shootings before
but here you hear the the the scene and
you watch the people go down and you see
the scramble and it was as vivid as
anything I can remember I I don't even
want to say more tragic because they're
all so tragic but the volume here and
the randomness here you know and the
brutality where you were able to see it
you know people in my office were just
it was just enormous ly depressing and
everything I'm getting back from all of
the users on TMZ
you know this this one they all heard
this one really hurts you know you know
what bothers me and and I always feel
that young people are impressionable and
we've had all these incidences you had
Ferguson and for a long time the
narrative was hands up don't shoot and
and Michael Brown was shot in the back
none of which ended up being true or
what happened with Freddie gray or the
Cambridge police acted stupidly black
lives matter in all these groups what do
we want dead cops
we want them now I sometimes worry and
wonder that the this younger generation
may not have a full and complete
understanding of how dangerous police
work is a my hope I'm wrong on that but
one of that yeah I mean look I think
everybody knows police work is dangerous
and I think at the same time everybody
knows that sometimes police cross the
line it just does happen Sean in any
profession people cross the line a
percentage everybody at tiny come shop
and I understand that but what I'm
saying is I think that if anything is
happening now I think people are just at
some point they're just saying stop this
violence you know it's like you one side
can blame another side another side can
blend that side but the fact is the
violence keeps happening and at a point
what's you know what good is it to say
oh you didn't know you did it oh no you
did it it's like at a point it's just
got to stop because this is impacting
the way we live now I mean this is do
you go to an outdoor concert do you go
to a movie theater do you send your kid
through school what about flying I mean
at a point if you look at it this
everything is closing in on us and to me
it's not about blame it's this this has
got to stop this is got Justin oh I
totally agree I love the fact that
there's kind of two sides of you you
know there's the funny outrageous crazy
Harvey that I've known for years and you
you or have a really serious side and
your new shows been a big hit on the
channel and you did Simon Cowell and
Judge Judy and this weekend you're doing
a really good a big friend of mine
Prime Minister Netanyahu I want to run a
quick clip and it runs Sunday night at
8:00 I went to an American high school
in the 60s right can you imagine you
went to Chilton Hamm high school yeah so
be honest with me who's the most famous
alum you are Reggie Jackson in Israel me
in America Reggie Jackson by you know a
hundred yards oh my gosh you know I love
well first of all I know him personally
I love that you get these another side
of people you're asking questions that
they don't get asked in normal
interviews and and look the idea here is
to me it's almost a psychological hour
that I want to know how these enormous
ly successful people accomplished people
became who they are today with lessons
they learned along the way and you know
with with the prime minister
you know he I'm sure you know the Shan
but we really got into it he he has a
disdain for politics and aggressively
does not want his children to be
political or to be to run for office he
has he finds it suffocating and he finds
it cruel and you know he talks to me
about this and I knew about how much his
brother's death impacted him but to sit
there and talk to him about it and
really kind of get into it and watch him
cry was really moving to me that that's
the raid on Entebbe
alright objective file the I promise
I'll be watching I won't miss us it's
hosted by Harvey Levin Sunday night 8:00
p.m. Eastern right here on Fox